a rare televised hearing in Israel's
High Court allowing the public to watch
for themselves the latest round of the
political crisis they've been living
with for more than a year after three
elections will there finally be a
government this week the first issue is
the assignment of a Knesset member to
form a government against whom charges
have been filed five out of eight
appeals are concerning this issue the
second issue has to do with the validity
of the coalition agreement that was
signed on April 20th that agreement for
a rotating co-equal Premiership between
Benjamin Netanyahu and his former rival
Benny Gantz requires changes to Israel's
fundamental basic laws to allow each
mistrustful partner the guarantees they
want to ensure the deal sticks Sunday
though saw the focus on the other issue
whether Benjamin Netanyahu indicted in
three separate corruption cases could
legally form and lead a new government
the law requires ministers in such a
position to resign but not Prime
Minister's Netanyahu is both a caretaker
Prime Minister and a candidate for the
job leaving room for legal argument
during it the justices seemed to signal
that they would not overrule what they
see as the will of the members of
Israel's parliament not a message
popular with anti Netanyahu
anti-coalition protesters who'd gathered
to watch proceedings in a park lying
symbolically between the court and the
Parliament as well as the critical
juncture in Israel's long-running
political crisis this is a major moment
for its constitution Netanyahu's legal
team argues that the Knesset the Israeli
Parliament has made its decision and the
court should not intervene his opponents
argue that allowing for a government to
be led by a man under such serious
criminal charges represents an
earthquake to the rule of law it's now
up to the justices to decide for now
Gantz and Netanyahu are still working to
pass the legislation required to form
the new government before the deadline
expires on Thursday if that doesn't
happen or if the court were to surprise
everyone and rule it out then Israel
would be
for a fourth election in less than 18
months with its political system
straining at the scenes
Harry Fawcett al Jazeera West Jerusalem